[Music]
all right as we continue with
congressman Devin Nunez he is the
chairman of the House Intelligence and
again I want to reiterate for our
audience it literally says steel gathers
information from Russian government
sources inside of Russia then it goes on
to say mr. steel in litigation it
appears he either lied to the FBI or to
the British courts or the classified
documents reviewed by the committee
contain materially false statements then
it says this the timeline here is
important about James Comey it says a
former FBI director in June of 2017
James called me publicly before the
Senate Select Committee on Intelligence
he had said that he he briefed
president-elect Trump this is a Trump
Tower and he told him and described the
dossier is salacious and unverified now
that's long after Comey signed off on
that information being used as a
foundation to get the FISA warrant so
would he he handed to the court
something he believed was unverified and
salacious or he gave a credibility when
they got the initial FISA warrant which
is it do you see a conflict there like I
do well I think the conflict that you're
describing which is which no one on the
left seems to care about or the
mainstream media is that political dirt
was used by the FBI and they knew it was
political dirt to open a
counterintelligence investigation into
the other campaign that's what people I
just can't believe that people on the
other side are not furious about this
but but look I have faith in the
American people I think that a majority
of Americans ultimately will make the
determination that using political dirt
by the FBI on the opposing campaign is a
place that that we won't go and I'll
tell you I think that my colleagues here
in the house I mean they're they're
furious about this as they should be
well let me ask you said that you
believe your colleagues on the other
side of the aisle have leaked
intelligence at least a hundred times is
that true yeah we have a hundred
examples of leaks from our committee
that we feel could have only come from
the other side
all right let's talk a little bit about
Sarah Carter's article tonight because I
think it's very very interesting she has
two of them as you look at this new this
new memo that came out tonight the
criminal referral confirms that allies
of the Clinton and Obama administration
we're providing steel with what they
deemed damaging information on candidate
elect Trump and it that's where we get
into for example Sidney Blumenthal and
some other Clinton associates let me see
if I'm understanding this correctly is
it possible sir that Clinton associates
were feeding information to Christopher
Steele and I refer back to you know one
other part of the redacted memo in the
Senate where it says there's substantial
evidence that mr. Steele materially
misled the FBI about a key aspect of his
dossiers efforts is it possible that
Clinton associates gave information to
Christopher Steele that was a news first
salacious dossier on Hillary's opponent
that was then used to lie to the
American people or mislead the American
people because Steele leaked all over to
the mainstream media and then was used
as the basis for a FISA is that possible
that some of the information came from
Clinton's own people to steal you're not
gonna you're not gonna like this answer
Shawn but it's the one I have to give
you partially why that's redacted
senator Grassley's the letters redacted
and you know it's still whatever is
there is classified we can't get in I
read you part but I can but what I can
tell you that is this we have an active
investigation into the State Department
that has been ongoing for a while now
and as soon as we can get that
information out we will as the
investigation unfolds I haven't been
wrong yet congressman and all of this
how do we how is it possible and this is
my final question I have I look I could
keep you on the air for the full hour
how is it possible that this is
happening in the United States of
America that is all of this combined
that you have Russian information from
apparently a known liar who has Russian
paid sources that then it's paid for by
one campaign and that's bad enough that
takes it up
to another notch so you have Russian
lies propaganda paid for by one
candidate then that pay propaganda is
used to go before a FISA Court and the
top people at the FBI and DOJ don't
inform the court about the underlying
dossier being bought and paid for by
that other candidate for the very person
they're trying to get a FISA memo on
it's it's what happens in banana
republics it's very scary I imagine the
you know we found out about this last
March not all of it
but we knew that the dossier was used to
some degree and it took us as you as you
well know subpoena in the DOJ and FBI
having to move close to going to
contempt it took speaker Ryan telling
them that they were basically going to
be held in contempt and finally we were
able to break loose all of the
documentation and then we were able to
get it out to the American people in the
form of the memo that is now is now out
and available for people to read and I
think people should go and read the memo
I really do if you if your viewers have
not written read the memo it's it's
worth your time I think it'll be very
illuminating all right chairman Nunez I
believe you've done a great service I
believe it's the right thing to do the
American people need to know about all
of this because fundamentally we had an
effort to undermine our election and
then undermine an incoming president is
that a fair statement last question
yeah I mean look I think there's clear
there's there's clear evidence of
collusion that the Democratic Party and
the Hillary Clinton campaign colluded
with the Russians okay you don't get it
you don't get to hire lawyers to pretend
like that didn't happen the very things
it goes to what what what they accuse
you of is what they actually were doing
unbelievable all right sir thank you so
much we appreciate it
my pleasure